but they're great role models i think
for me in particular like i try to
conduct myself the way i think they
would 100 their relationship goals
i actually go by a different name now
his name is hyrum every gangster has an
origin story
you are playing the younger version of
your dad on a hit tv show and then to
promote the episode you went on to your
mom's nationally syndicated morning talk
show to talk about it how would you
describe your life these days how
surreal is that michael well first of
all i'm really grateful i've had
opportunities that uh you know a lot of
people haven't and that aren't genuinely
i'm very grateful for for everything i
have and but on the other end it's so
funny because you know i grew up on
mom's show like i was there when i was
like after school and like before i even
went to school i was hanging out on that
set so it was really surreal being a
guest on it i think yeah i know it's
cool to go to work with your parents a
little bit you know i mean obviously at
a certain point i i think the next step
would be to not play my dad i guess but
again i'll do it as many times as i can
i love it but no complaints no
complaints it was awesome how do you
feel about the pictures of mommy and
daddy when she posts them oh
[Music]
i've got to give you major props for the
way that you call out your parents's
behavior in such a public setting what
is that like for you to be like mom dad
you gotta come on man everyone can see
this it's like a little version of what
we do at home like our family we're a
bunch of jokers we like to rip on each
other a lot and kid around and it just
it spills out into like the social media
and all that but it's just it's just
home you know that's just how we are i
love the fact that your mom kelly ripa
she's so beloved by fans and people have
known her for so long but at the end of
the day she's a mom of three she's your
mama what is one thing that you think
that audiences would be surprised to
know about her that you know it's really
bizarre well yeah she's my mom she's
beloved by us too but she's more tech
savvy than i am which is hilarious no
she's like i don't know what it is about
technology but i'm just horrible with it
and i'll ask it's really funny because
you know usually the the idea is that
the kids help their parents with
technology it's the other way around for
me my parents are both very tech savvy
and my mom in particular it's wild it's
wild you know your parents just
celebrated their 25th wedding
anniversary which is just so incredible
and such an amazing accomplishment when
you look at your parents do you see them
as relationship goals does that inspire
you to want to find someone special man
i mean i think anyone would uh not just
exclusive to me but yeah but they're
they're very they're great not just in
like a relationship sense but they're
great role models i think for me in
particular like i try to conduct myself
the way i think they would
100 their relationship cults
and it's weird because like i've been
with them the longest like not a year
after they were married a year about
yeah about a year then i came into the
picture so we kind of kind of grew up
together i think at least that's how i
see it so is there anyone in your love
life right now not in the moment um i'm
just kind of you know i think i'm
starting out on the acting trail and i'm
early in it so the goal right now is
employment you know as it is for people
starting out so one bridge to cross at a
time
you had always said you could see
yourself behind the camera but then you
kind of fell in love with acting what is
next for you and what would be your
dream role man i don't really know about
the dream role i mean beggars and
choosers but uh yeah i know it's um an
interesting progression realizing
because midnight club gave my first
little taste of it and i loved that and
it carried over
oh i had it beforehand weirdly i don't
know from what but like i did
i think maybe from from being on mom's
show in the past i don't know but i had
that which is why i was able to do uh
midnight club in the first place
actually so yeah that and then in school
like
because i went to film school my friends
and classmates would need people to act
in their movies i did that and
gave me another little taste and then
this and hopefully the next step is
more you know i'm hungry for more and
we'll see what comes from it i will
finish what my father began
you're unstoppable
[Music]